what is going on what is going on and he
wants to rest Michael why don't you call
your girlfriend I don't have a
girlfriend but you said you went out of
this weekend get the pole it's broken
right you can't come Oh Dwight oh he's
still driving too white
you forgot your bumper does the skin
look red and swim that's what she said
that's my joke damn it Dwight
so yesterday Dwight found half a joint
in the parking lot which is unfortunate
because as it turns out Dwight finding
drugs is more dangerous than most people
using drugs let's go over some of these
symptoms of marijuana use shall we you
tell me who this sounds like slow-moving
inattentive dull constantly snacking
shows a lack of motivation
hey I like the people I work with
generally with four exceptions but
someone committed a crime and I did not
become a Lackawanna County volunteer
sheriff's deputy to make friends and by
the way I haven't
hi Linda Dwight Schrute assistant
regional manager
you might remember testing my year in a
few years back when I was applying to be
a volunteer sheriff's deputy we test a
lot of yarn mine was Green oh right how
are you I'm all better so I need you to
do some work on the st. Andrews account
I need your urine I need some filing
done what kind of filings Cumberland
Mills and how did you give my resume oh
no no I'm very flattered don't get me
wrong I'm just not sure that it's my
official resume or if it's something
that maybe a satisfied customer posted
online what does it say under martial
arts training oh okay I'm gonna have to
supplement that could I have your fax
number would I ever leave this company
look I'm all about loyalty in fact I
feel like part of what I'm gonna be paid
for here is my loyalty but if there were
somewhere else that valued that loyalty
more highly I'm going wherever they
value loyalty the most hey hey how'd the
run go
oh pretty good I finished that's great
why is that great because they
accomplished something
what was your mild time about seven I
can beat that on a skateboard well that
has wheels yeah well my feet don't and I
can still crush that time really Dwight
not faster you let's just put it this
way last weekend
I outran a black pepper snake really I
am fast to give you a reference point
I'm somewhere between a snake and a
mongoose
and a panther man what is shaking Toby
so long oh I'll just time him later and
you'll compare the times yeah are you
ready no I can't
am I being mean to Dwight I don't know I
did just make him run around the
building and I have no intention of
timing him
this isn't even a stopwatch it's a
digital thermometer on or off off what
is on your face is that a disguise clown
paint ID badges are long overdue
security in this office Park is a joke
last year I came to work with my spud
gun in a duffel bag I set up my desk all
day with a rifle that shoots potatoes at
60 pounds per square inch can you
imagine if I was deranged okay with all
due respect to everyone here I think the
most worthy opponent of you is you that
is correct
unless there happened to be measles
present so let's just say that Dwight
has come at you with the throat punch
now how would you do it-- defend against
it easy allow me to demonstrate
i am attacking myself with a throat
punch here it comes
block grasp wrist as such and what if he
comes at you with the other hand because
he does have to good point second throat
punch absorb the blow groin punch hit
block elbows in the gut Oh up to the
nose no you're not ah oh oh my god he's
making you look like such a fool he
really is but not for long Oh God instep
oh not again ha ha you let go you let go
oh you're right look at hold on oh
you're so evenly matched I don't know
how one of you is gonna get the upper
hand the important thing to remember Jim
we always have what is called the
element of surprise okay I will only
need two things
the roll of duct tape and a knife I'm on
it okay 30 minutes relax please come
back save the receipts
Hey what hey wait wait
I keep various weaponry strategically
placed around the office
I saved Jim's life with a can of pepper
spray
I had velcroed under my desk people say
oh it's dangerous to keep weapons in the
home or the workplace well I say it's
better to be hurt by someone you know
accidentally than by a stranger on
purpose Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim
Jim Jim oh hey Dwight
I am gonna be your new boss it's my
greatest dream come true welcome to the
hotel hell check-in time is now checkout
time is never does my room enough table
no and the sheets are made of fire
controls sorry we're all booked up hell
convention in town can I wait check out
I'll have to talk to the manager you're
not the manager even in your own fantasy
I'm the owner
the co-owner with Satan okay just so I
understand that in your wildest fantasy
you are in hell and you are co running a
bed-and-breakfast with the devil yeah
but I haven't told you my salary yet go
$80,000 a year
once I am officially Regional Manager my
first order of business will be to
demote Jim Halpert so I will need a new
number two my ideal choice Jack Bauer
but he is unavailable fictional and
overqualified they will cost you your
life elaborate the worst thing you can
do for your immune system is to coddle
it they need to fight their own battles
if Sabre really cared about our
well-being they would set up handy
sanitizing stations a simple Bowl at
every juncture filled with dirt vomit
fecal matter exposing yourself to germs
is the best way to make yourself
stronger so by that rationale
if I had to sneeze I should just sneeze
on you yes I would welcome it you're
welcome
the principle is sound to avoid illness
expose yourself to germs enabling your
immune system to develop antibodies hurt
you
I don't know why everyone doesn't do
this maybe they have something against
living forever what is the most
inspiring thing I've ever said to you
don't be an idiot
changed my life whenever I'm about to do
something I think would an idiot do that
and if they would I do not do that thing
therefore a piece of chocolate chocolate
where did you acquire it
that is the delicacy in the Amazon but
it has not yet been imported to the
United States who is the king of
Austrian Joseph ii who is he King of
Prussia Friedrich Wilhelm the third what
is the king of England why the tyrant
King George of course I don't care what
Jim says that is not the real Ben
Franklin I am 99% sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
seriously okay okay yes I have a wig for
every single person in the office you
never know when you're gonna need to
bear a passing resemblance to someone I
just want it to stop
you